Lilla lately so we get Marvel movies in
the form of Disney movies now it's a
good time to be alive
just sayin life is good big hero six so
big hero six is a disney animation of a
marvel property about a kid he's a
really smart kid whose brother makes
this really likable plush squishy
science robot michelin man looking guy
at baymax and in baymax in the main kid
named Hiro they go on their adventures
what I love about this movies before the
adventure even began they made science
school this group of youth in the movie
that become relevant players in the
movie later on they have their science
fair stuff you're like that's awesome
that's I like science fair stuff we're
gonna get right into the fact that
baymax is I would say too likely he's so
damn likable you want to hug baymax
she's big marshmallow you're like ah
like a big stuffed animal he's nice and
lovable but he's kind of he's not an
idiot he's just uninformed he's
programmed to do his certain things we
has tunnel vision so he doesn't get the
complexities of human emotion or traffic
laws and it makes for some really funny
scenarios in the movie the villain they
got to take on was like Doc Ock from
hell he has like all these little
nanobots that just carry them around on
waves of nanobots and they create arms
of Nana bhai's it's really cool organ
now the crew of friends in the movie
while they are cool and they're like a
group of Goonies in an animation with
science smarts like everyone in the
Goonies was data from the Goonies they
don't have a lot of development it's
like they're introduced and then they're
not in the movie for a while and then
they come in the movie with a bunch of
cool gear which is neat I like seeing
them with cool gear but it does feel
like they were thrown into it you're
like yeah but baymax he's what I care
about in the movie and I will say there
were a couple of pacing issues
throughout the movie movies an hour and
a half long so it doesn't feel like
there should be pacing issues I had a
point I was like this movie does feel
kind of like it's dragging on and then I
hear a couple kids well one kid behind
me one kid to the left of me and they're
both like mom how long was this movie
when your target audience starts feeling
like things are standing still it's not
good it was only like that for really
one point in the movie and then it sped
up and was exciting until the end just
got to address the fact that it kind of
slowed down at appointments it just
depress me that modern day animations
don't have the guts to go that extra
foot you don't have to go the extra mile
just the foot like there's a scene where
something is happening it's a lot of
emotion and then the main kid hero he's
like but my tragedy happened earlier on
I can tell you but it happened like what
he's gone I was like no it would have
been more impactful if you had just said
but he's dead death is just a reality of
life it doesn't necessarily freak kids
out it's just real you can say dead it's
not gonna mess anyone up in the head
back they didn't I saw that in
Maleficent also I was like she will go
to sleep didn't say die you know it's
just things like that makes me go ah why
but it is a really fun time the world
looked Austin I just looked at the world
that was like that is a hybrid of San
Francisco and Tokyo just what it's
supposed to be I love big hero six it
was a great time it was a good adventure
I love the main character hero I loved
baymax a hero six definitely worth
checking out go watch if you have a
family go take them parents kids
everyone will be entertained I will say
big hero six is definitely worth buying
on blu-ray I will say this at a point in
the movie I was like watch out for Star
Fox his dad he's in here somewhere
he'll know what I'm talking about and
there is a Stan Lee cameo if you can
find it's in the movie there's a big
hero 6 have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more